[Epic Voiceover]: "It had been many years since I'd last seen him."
"I wondered how he was doing."
"I found myself thinking about him on... long nights."
"What if I was wrong?"
"What if I had been blind?"
"What if Pokémon™, WERE real."
"It took me a long time to track him down, but after three years..."
"I found him."
[Dramatic music]
[Intense pipe/flute music]
[Gruff voice] YA DIDN'T SEE ME.
(Totally Didn't)
But here I am.
BEAST MASTER 64 again.
[spits]
I've caught every single Pokémon™
EXCEPT ONE.
-the Gyriedadoe-
-the Gariedos.
-the Jew-
-the georiedora.
(._.)
-The Georados
You may be wondering why I'm wearing this.
There's no water.
But an insider tip told us-
-TheBeastMaster64 Tumblr blog
Someone commented, that dern guy-rydose...
Is out there.
[Gyarados mating call.]
(Dem Graphics)
Pewds: Excuse me
Pewds: Have you seen the GYRADOS?
Lady: Sorry?
Pewds: The GYRADOS, have you seen it?
Pewds: It's over there?
Lady: ???
Pewds: Is it over there? [giggles]
SHE SAID SHE KNEW EXACTLY WHERE IT WAS.
I NEVER FELT SO ALIVE.
We're close, boys.
We're close.
It's out there.
Callin' my name:
"BEAST MASTER 64."
I'm comin' for ya.
I'm comin'.
[Gyarados mating call]
This is mah boat.
The CSGO LOTTOOEE.™
Where's your boat, KSI?
[Smacks boat]
Bet you can't afford this.
The CSGO Lotto has set every record there is...
Except one.
TO CATCH THE GUY-RADOEDOSE.
[Gyarados mating call]
"Wait, do you expect me to get in this boat with you?"
Who the fuck is gonna documentary it?
"This a $5000 camera--"
"And it's just-- I don't wanna be in the water."
What are you a fuckin' Magikarp?
[Defensively] "NO."
'o_o`
"LET'S GO!"
YEAH BRO.
C'MON BRO.
[Dramatic Music]
Alright! What's your name, documentary man?
"My name's Brad--"
I DON'T GIVE A SHIT, WE'RE GOING OUT RIGHT NOW.
"Oh my Go--"
HURRY THE FUCK UP, THE TIDE, THERE'S A STORM COMIN'.
ARRGHHH!
ARGH!
ARRGH!
[Indistinctive yelling]
ARGH!
HURRY UP!
I NEED YOU TO GET THE WATER OUT, WE'RE SINKING.
WATER YOU DOIN?!
"THIS IS A BAD IDEA!"
THIS IS MY ONLY CHANCE!!
IT'S THEM.
[far-off Gyarados mating call]
GET THE BOAT.
"I believe you!"
GET THE BOAT- GET-
THE POKÉ-BITCH™
I'M GONNA HAVE TO SEND THE POKÉ-BITCH.™
AW, C'MON POKÉ-BITCH.™
GO, POKÉ-BITCH!™
ARGHHH!
C'MON!
OOHH!
GET 'EM!
(R.I.P POKE-BITCH)
DON'T FILM IT!
We lost one of the propell- [drops]
-_-
GO!
We're gonna have to go out manually.
(NUUUU!!!)
IF I DON'T COME BACK...
MAKE IT LOOK GOOD.
[Sad Music]
[Voiceover]: "Seeing him dejected on that beach..."
"It was in that moment that I knew..."
"Everything he had been searching for..."
"Was REAL."
(Nahhh... Really... *Sarcasm*)
"The Gyrados..."
"...was real."
"...and I had to see it for myself."
"This wasn't the end."
"He had to go back out there..."
"...And I was going with him."
[Dramatic music, building]
[Unintelligible talking]
IT'S NOW OR NEVER.
I KNEW YOU HAD IT IN YA, BOI.
When I come back...
I'm gon' be a legend
CAMERAMAN!
THERE'S WATER IN IT.
Jesus...
(Agony)
[yelling]
(Wheeeeeeee!!!)
[High pitched scream]
Tell me one thing.
DO YOU BLEED?
[Talking over Pewds] "C'mon Beast Master."
(I'm Batman!)
They said I would never catch it.
But they were WRONG.
"You're wearing a life jacket, Beast Master 64. Should I be wearing a life jacket?"
Oh, absolutely.
[Dramatic music pauses]
I can't swim.
(-_-)
"You can't swim?"
I can't swim
"I can't swim."
(REALLY!?!)
[Dramatic music resumes]
You know what the worst way of... dying is?
"Gyrados."  "\_(I_I)_/"
Yeah.
*music paused*
[Laughing] That was it.
Getting eaten by one.
[Dramatic music continues]
(Bum!)
We're getting close now, Cameraman.
OH! We're gonna be legends.
We goin' be fuckin' le-
THERE IT IS!  )(0.0)(
[Totally Real Gyrados roars]
"OH MY GOD!"
"OHH MY GOD!!"
[Sad piano]
Cameraman,
It's been a pleasure workin' by your side.
But once I go in, I won't make it back.
"What do you mean, 'go in?'" (Dats what she said)
You knew that since we begun.
"Wha..?"
You knew since we started.
"You have to catch it manually?"
I have to catch it manually, you're right.
"I will continue your legacy."
"After you're gone."
"You've made a believer out of me."
"I'm gonna download POKÉMON GO!" (-o-)
[Both Pewds and Brad laugh]
[Dramatic music again]
"OH MY GOD, THERE IT IS!"
There it is.  [Totally not a Godzilla™ Roar]
There it is... IT'S RIGHT THERE!
[SQUEAK]
Remember me.
Cameraman.
[Roars]
(Wait I thought he couldn't swim...)
[Totally Real Crying, laughter]
[In Distance] REMEMBER ME!
[More crying]
REMEMBER ME!
[Even more crying]
(Eh.. It's Probably just me)
OOUUUGH!
[More crying]
[Gasping for air]
"What happened?"
He didn't make it.
Cameraman!
The sea swallowed him...
(Whaaaaaa!?!?)
And I didn't get the Guh-Gyrados.
(Great Prununciation)
[spits]
What a fuckin' bitch.
People don't understand.
It's dangerous.
(Finally!)
I'm goin' out again.
(Face Palm)
[Dramatic music]